setting up an AdWords campaign can be
pretty simple you start by creating your
ad settings then writing when your offer
is in the ad next choose the keywords
you want people to use when they're
searching for your ad then set your
daily budget and bidding just those few
steps you're ready to go live however
before you do this you're going to need
to set up your overall account settings
now when you're doing this be sure to
check out the instructions on how to do
it once you set your country and your
currency you're unable to go back and
change it so after you complete your
settings you can make your ad campaign
your ad campaign is built out by
different ad groups each ad group has
its own add keywords and bids and all of
these share the same budget location
targeting timing and settings different
campaigns can help you organize
categories of your products or your
services that you offer and when you're
starting the campaign you're gonna need
to customize your settings these
settings include things like location
languages bidding strategy budget ad
extensions things like that Google has a
ton of documentation on each one of
these settings that you can check out
there's a link in the instructor notes
for this but don't worry you can adjust
your bid strategy or budgeting at any
time actually not only can you do this
you're really encouraged to do it so
that way you can optimize your campaign
regularly based on the performance of an
ad group or even the individual ad and
keywords that you have so once your
keywords in place you can start creating
your ad group structure so from the top
level you're going to start with your
account which is connected to your
username email address password and
billing info and you can have various
campaigns under one account that are
going to share the same general settings
from there you can have ad groups nested
under a single campaign we're going to
title our first campaign customer
acquisition promo offer because we're
gonna offer new members to abarkment a
15% off coupon and later we can set up
different campaigns that are going to
run at the same time to achieve
different goals so we may want to do
brand awareness or a special campaign
for the holidays or summer vacations
based on the seasonality we noticed in
Google Trends the first ad group is
going to be dog owners and the second ad
group is going to be dog sitters we
separated these out because we want
different ads and different messaging
for our different groups our dog series
may want to hear about the ex
income they're going to receive on the
other hand our dog owners may want to
hear about the luxury we offer or the
safe environment we're offering their
dogs well their way and from there we're
going to develop our ads and different
keywords that are specific for each
group